[Música]
se cumplen 12 años desde el inicio de la
guerra en Siria una de las mayores
crisis humanitarias del mundo la
organización
ha dicho que más de 15 millones de
personas en todo el país dependen de la
ayuda humanitaria se calcula que solo en
las zonas del noroeste controladas por
la oposición había uno coma nueve
millones de desplazados Y eso hasta
antes de los terremotos de febrero la
mayoría de ellos mujeres niños y niñas
después de la última tragedia al menos
86.000 personas más quedaron
damnificadas y desplazadas vamos a hacer
el análisis de esta situación con Susana
mangana ella es profesora e
investigadora del instituto de derechos
humanos de la Universidad de deusto
Bilbao Muchas gracias a usted Susana por
estar en directo América
Muchas gracias a ti Ángela por este
contacto comienzo preguntándole Por qué
occidente le retiró su atención a Siria
incluso antes de la guerra en Ucrania
son doce años de una de las crisis
humanitarias más grandes de la historia
actual
Bueno yo creo que hayan jugado factores
tales como por ejemplo el desgaste de
una guerra que ya es una guerra
justamente
latente es una guerra de desgaste entre
los bandos en conflicto la oposición
Siria y el gobierno de alasaz Pero toda
vez que tácticamente o militarmente el
gobierno de alasat ha ganado esta guerra
que no significa que haya ganado en el
territorio el control de todo el país
como tú bien indicabas todavía hay
bastiones de lo que llamamos Los
Rebeldes en la prensa occidental o de la
oposición Siria sobre todo al norte al
noroeste y al nordeste también del país
lo que ocurre es que han ocurrido otros
sucesos no solo la pandemia la
recuperación a partir de lo que
significó el covid 19 en el mundo Pero
también esta Guerra de Ucrania Rusia que
ha distraído la atención de la Unión
Europea y sobre todo de Estados Unidos y
toda vez que entendieron que no tenían
un recambio para el gobierno de alasat
válido y no sabían A quién poner en el
lugar visto lo que ha ocurrido con Sadam
en Ángela usted como cree que es hoy la
situación después de los terremotos en
Siria en su conocimiento sobre la zona
Bueno es muy lamentable porque un país
como Siria que tenía un nivel de vida si
lo comparábamos con países de la región
de oriente medio y otros Países Árabes
Como yemen por ejemplo muy superior hoy
han vuelto a aparecer enfermedades
infecciosas como tuberculosis como el
cólera por lo que es la falta de agua
potable por lo que es la falta de
higiene y sobre todo de atención
primaria de salud porque tenemos que
entender que ha quedado muy maltrecha la
infraestructura sanitaria pero no solo
eso Y es que el país tiene una inflación
rampante galopante no la pueden
controlar y por otro lado el país no
tiene las arcas del estado como tenía
antes de la guerra para invertir en
reconstrucción con lo cual como tú
decías 15 millones de sirios Necesitan
desesperadamente ayuda humanitaria para
sobrevivir Pero esto afecta
especialmente a población vulnerable
ancianos mujeres jóvenes lactantes y los
niños pequeños
los crímenes para la humanidad que hemos
visto en más de una década de
cubrimiento de estos enfrentamientos
siguen impunes y le quiero hablar aquí
de los ataques con gas sarín que fueron
titulares internacionales ataques por
ejemplo a niños que quedaron
completamente en el olvido Qué pasó con
eso Bueno lo que ocurre Es que la
geopolítica tiene esta estas vericuetos
verdad esta situación ingrata donde los
países que dicen defender los derechos
humanos muchos de ellos conocidos por
todos potencias europeas o el propio
Canadá no siempre es solo Estados Unidos
o el propio Japón después olvidan esto
cuando les conviene eso pesar o de
alguna manera están calculando y
especulando que ganan y que pierden
entonces han preferido dejar en el poder
a un tirano como es al asad y toda su
familia Porque no gobierna solo basar a
las gobierna todo el circuito todo el
entorno de bajadas sus hermanos y todo
lo que es la élite que gobernaba ya una
élite muy vetusta que gobernaba con su
padre y dejan de lado esa defensa de los
Derechos Humanos ahí vemos lo que ocurre
en un vecino que tiene mucho que ver con
la interna de Siria como es en la
República es la mica de Irán donde
también han recurrido en las últimas
semanas al envenenamiento de niñas de
escolares muy jovencitas con el fin de
amedrentar a la población entonces mucho
me temo Angela que este crimen de lesa
humanidad el ataque a civiles
indiscriminado con armas químicas armas
letales como también la desaparición
forzosa y la muerte presumiblemente de
más de 500.000 personas la inmensa
mayoría civiles en Siria va a quedar
totalmente impune quisiera que donáramos
un poco acerca de la salida imposible de
bachar al azar y queda entonces que la
resignación a que el régimen termine de
establecerse como una dictadura usted lo
estaba diciendo azade lleva ya 23 años
gobernando antes de ello su familia en
cabeza de su padre también lo hizo en
conjunto durante más décadas
exactamente era una República
hereditaria así lo llamaba hafesalasat
hay que entender que basar a la Sata
ahora en imágenes no era el hijo
predilecto Para ocupar el cargo de
sucesor del padre pero su hermano mayor
va a ser murió en un accidente de
tráfico porque era muy afecto a la
velocidad al vicio al alcohol eso
también hay que decirlo verdad una
familia que no ha dudado en vivir por
encima de las posibilidades de la media
normal de un ciudadano sirio ahora bien
no hay un plan recambio para basar en la
sala yo creo que hay que entender que ni
biden en conjunto Estados Unidos ni la
Unión Europea hoy tienen un plan
recambio para este gobierno y por tanto
van a tener que lidiar con él por mucho
tiempo más ahora preocupa Cómo salir de
la guerra todavía sin sin luz al final
del túnel de Rusia y Ucrania una
guerrilla de una guerra de expansión de
Rusia hacia Ucrania y que recordar y por
tanto la preocupación de Estados Unidos
hoy pasa por otras cuestiones internas y
a nivel internacional la rivalidad
comercial y política Si se quiere con
china esta guerra con Rusia y Ucrania
que los tiene muy acotados porque mucho
del gasto va hay una carrera
armamentista pero sobre todo el gasto
militar va ahora a parar a manos de
zelenski en Ucrania con lo cual Siria
Dejó de ser un problema Siria está
relativamente controlado entonces Siria
depende de la ayuda de Rusia y de Irán
para continuar alimentando a este
régimen que ha tiranizado a la población
y que hoy realmente tenemos entre 13
millones de desplazados forzosos
internos y refugiados que malviven en
campos de refugiados en Jordania en
Egipto en Turquía más de tres millones
de sirios en algunos países de
latinoamérica incluso hemos recibido
también a refugiados sirios con lo cual
vive en un infierno desde hace 12 años Y
eso va a continuar así y cada vez se
agrava más la situación interna por la
inflación porque se ha contraído la
economía porque muchas empresas han
deslocalizado su economía y se la han
llevado su producción a países como
Jordania como Egipto relativamente más
estables entonces o muchos no tienen
trabajo lo han perdido o las
infraestructuras de desarrollo económico
del país incluso la agricultura ha
quedado muy maltrecha con lo cual Siria
es un país que se ha empobrecido
muchísimo se ha contraído su economía
más de un 200% Entonces esto realmente
es muy muy grave y no hablemos del
expectativa de vida de una generación
que solamente ha crecido conociendo la
guerra y que no tiene posibilidades de
aspirar a calidad de vida eso es Susana
mangana profesora e investigadora del
instituto de derechos humanos de la
Universidad de deusto Bilbao gracias a
usted
Gracias a ti Ángela nosotros continuamos
en directo América quédense ya volvemos
con más
[Música]